this is Marvel Live Marvel let's play
I'm Josh Thole I'm Nora Davis man
welcome guys thank you you gonna get a
chance to see Iron Man VR for
PlayStation VR and I got a great honor
introducing the creator from camouflage
get out for Ryan paint right here
everybody thanks for coming out how you
feeling I'm feeling great this is an
opportunity to show the game off to
people this is awesome me and Josh got
the opportunity to play it man and this
is just so exciting that the fans that
comic-con finally get to see it and I
just got to say before we start Congrats
oh thank you it's a beautiful game No
thank you no it's been a long time
coming over three years in development
working very closely with our partners
at PlayStation Marvel everybody is super
passionate about making the best Iron
Man experience possible and pairing that
with VR it's just a dream come true yes
man it is fantastic
[Music]
morning sir our travel time to Shanghai
is 11 hours 15 minutes told you we
should have taken a faster flight I
think the board prefers you wear a more
conventional suit to these company
meetings you can't outrun your past
Friday tell me I didn't just imagine
that negative sir incoming a little late
don't you think
Friday suit up now
[Music]
all systems are like
so those inbound 10 o'clock so much for
a hero's welcome
oh no right
we're up against you made your share of
enemies on the whole time
I love you
that's how it's done
threat neutralized good I have a plane
to catch
[Music]
man Ryan that is fire my heart is
pumping duck hell just you wait we're
gonna play some gameplay yeah really
it's racing I love when the bombers does
not gameplay all right all right so Josh
we gonna get you suited and booted right
hashtag shoot up a mall right yes come
on right do it so we gonna get Josh
suited into the PlayStation VR Marvel's
Ironman VR right now and we're gonna
give you a live demo of the game so you
could check it out
and Ryan tell us a little bit back story
of like creating a game the process
getting to getting to this point yeah
absolutely so it all started with the
prototype it started about a prototype
about how do we do flying as Ironman in
VR yeah right that's such an incredible
challenge and something we didn't know
if we could overcome yeah and so the
team just worked incredibly hard to come
up with this initial prototype we took
it to Marvel we said what do you think
you think we've got it and they said
yeah you got it
that's great because you actually do
feel like you are Iron Man and I think
that's what all the fans I always want
we want to feel like we are Iron Man
feel like we're Hulk or cat but like
this you actually captured Iron Man is
off your checklist man Congrats oh thank
you there is kind of a checklist yeah in
terms of how you think about it right
you start off with the helmet yes with
it with the HUD with the repulsors with
the with the auxiliary weapons but yeah
we're looking at this original suit
original suit right there right
impulse our impulse armor the impulse
armor right there Josh how you feeling
[Music]
literally insane all right you getting a
little watt there you go that you got
your hands they got the wireframe and
with that house
how's that all come about Ryan right
yeah so what you're saying here is that
is the main menu for the game we've
created a little bit of special one for
for comic-con here but it's an
opportunity because one of the
challenges making the game is that you
are a first-person Iron Man right but
you don't think it's a Sia's suit all
the time if you're first-person so we
wanted to make sure that we had the
impulse armor here in the flesh so you
can see it and it kind of and look in
the incredible detail that the team and
an audiences ein is being represented
here man that drawing is just that's all
these design rights are these design
right there and it's beautiful man got
everything going there the chest is
blowing he he's now there we go yeah
playing baby let's get you in here
all right whoa all right so we've gotta
go let's play so we're gonna start off
in the first area got your hands it's
the first environment the players gonna
play in if that's right outside of
Tony's Malibu mansion and this is an
opportunity for players to learn exactly
how to fly yeah okay great so it's
always a flight simulator first I play
is how to fly how the shoot
exactly any other I mean that's just so
cool man like definitely gotta learn how
to fly and like Josh how you feeling
right now oh we get are we getting are
we getting it going we get it going I'm
pumped are you if anyone's got to be
able to play this at the Marvel booth
you know how exciting and exhilarating
this feeling was going to be and if it's
your first time seeing this gameplay
footage is just on this screen I hope
you're ready yeah we know we're ready
man we got hook up look up a little bit
are we got 74 seconds every game you got
always got gotta get that loaded it just
gets more exciting we just want to
actually make it longer just so you get
more excited this is also TJ we could do
it in a snap of the fingers that's no
fun get the details here we go baby all
right so we gonna get ya and then I'm is
this the original story that this is an
absolutely original story we created
with our lead writer Brendan Murphy and
the team over that question again
because here we go coming down coming
down keep your hands steady jaws keep
your head steady keep it steady there we
go there you go keep it nicest
Wow oh my gosh whoa we looking at Malibu
put your hands up oh man you are
Robocop baby no iron me all right so
everybody oh my god you are fly can you
look down a little bit so we can see
that I soo status he's in the hub right
now we can see you going north right
towards sony logo a got your repulses on
the right how's it feeling right now
come on up play up ha camouflage babies
dance fire fire keep your head nice and
steady there we go Marvel Iron Man VR
great it don't get no more prettier than
that is the baby ok ok good I'm glad the
baby's alright don't put some ice on the
baby check out the house yeah see the
Malibu smell dimension right there got
Tony's got Tony's house Stark's house
right there got the tennis court with
three courts yeah Serena could come and
practice and look at all the villages
out there dice million-dollar villa yeah
their mortgages are kind of crazy but
Tony's got the best house looking out
the window Oh telling you just flying
again yeah that's all he does is he be a
kind of a fun neighbor I would love to
get that house like there's telling
today you go how you feeling guys oh I'm
really living a dream right now do you
feel like you're high do you feel like
you're above the ground I'm flying over
everything right now and I'm shocked
nice keep your head nice are you going
to your garage yes nice landing on the
roof of your house hey Josh yeah when
you if you land somewhere we let's take
a look at your arms that's a nice view
there we go there we go get you on one
of your own beaches
so one of the things that the team did
really great is like working with Marvel
on that absolutely all the detail yeah
being able to not only see your hands in
VR but see your full arms connected to
your chest is zero
old suit in first person that's so
important right for the player to know
that they are Ironman they're playing as
Tony Stark
if you stretch your arms out if you
twist them around it doesn't clip
through the team is just an absolutely
incredible job working for many many
many months to make sure that this all
works perfectly yeah nothing nothing
looks distorted at all everything looks
very proportioned right nothing your
wrist the wrist look beautiful like
everything is just like he's making all
the movements exactly oh yeah there's a
lot of little Easter eggs here up
scattered throughout all the level of
detail we just you know we working again
working with really closely with Tim and
Bill over at Marvel to make sure that
tony's tony's management feels a very
high-tech you know what kind of mansion
would Tony Stark build won't have cool
elements like this couch all from Ikea
that's got that's a brand billionaire
idea jazz can you get to a fly a little
bit threw some rocks real quick do one
now fly through a rock get some speed
going there you go when that toys your
house leave your house alone don't want
a break yeah let's go this dip in there
damn that's nice so as you can see the
game is definitely not on Rails the game
is you could fly wherever you want to go
yeah if you can see that place like
within reason right you could fly there
going 250 miles an hour do you know you
can and driving around no man yeah all
right I got to be on the yeah I got some
bolsters now ok test out the repos all
right here we go
oh wow look at this so now up Oh cross
okay you could do the cross you can like
you can like tap it to and tap it make
it pull up you could do like kind of
click yeah like rapid-fire or you can
hold and hold the move button and then
charge up and then if you can hear also
like we know working with marble making
sure that you get that perfect sound of
like the wine as a try as the repulsors
charger sound effect is perfect man
[Laughter]
you got Stoney's you got tony stark's
attitude oh there you go keep nice there
you go so this is like a very quick
tutorial to make sure that players feel
comfortable not only shooting but flying
and shooting yes and that's like the
nest next step that we put players
through Josh you feel comfortable right
are you kidding me I feel more than
comfortable can you apply up and I put
your hands in front of you and I we can
see yeah there we go so now that now
people know that was realest and if you
can look down we can see the suit status
like people go that's right go to the
pool we'll take a look at your you're
stood service this is another really
cool feature the team worked on yes
because again as I talked about one of
the challenges is you're playing the
game in first person you don't see the
suit in third person like you might see
in other games right and so we want to
make sure the players knew that it was
constantly reminded that they are Tony
Stark they are Iron Man so there's a
real-time representation of the player
if you look down Josh a little further
you can see you can move your arms
around move your arms around Josh and
it's just so you know it's like 1 for 1
and make sure that wrist yeah exactly so
players can do if you turn around Josh
that's amore even better but look at
some better track no I don't know what
anything is on the stage right now yeah
so that was just a key big key kind of
cool thing we want to add to the game to
make sure the players are always
reminded that they are Iron Man sure you
can afford Josh let's go let's get you
doing some more repulsors man you got
three more three more targets to
destroying them get to the next thing
yeah then we introduce another mechanic
to the players again like I'm not
exaggerating over two years of
development of just the tutorial to
really teach the player how to play this
game because this isn't that hyperbole
nobody's played a game like this exact
we can't before yeah we can't go on to
you know Amazon and buy a bunch of games
and go like oh yeah we're gonna learn
exactly how you make a game where you
fly exact you you rock yeah it's just
like Iron Man so we have to teach the
player to play a game one like
think they've ever played before exactly
even like back a day I used to play that
game taka it sucked
I will always crash you're trying to win
on that this right here you feel
everything you definitely know what
you're doing you know how that
everything is controlled by you exactly
that is a great so here's another
mechanic route that josh is just about
to demonstrate this time it's not just
you can fly straight or fly wherever you
want to go up to 50 thrusters and he's
going now he's going 350 miles an hour
oh man sick sick this is insane bro
and then we're gonna have you double you
know double click those thrusters and
boost all the way into the cave and its
really really nice grotto grotto and you
know is this like the fly summer is it
inspired by actual flight simulator like
the direction and yeah absolutely
everything here is all physics based
we're not just making us would work in
real life
so here we have we're demonstrating
punch the TV's out in front of you right
so you got your flying you got your
boosting you got your shooting you also
got your rocket punch so now we got the
flying the booth and the rocket punch
right now so we're just trying to like
layer in those elements one minute or
another not try to make it too
overwhelming for the player you can rock
and punch that that target there Josh
good job it's so real man yeah it feels
like here yes she's so Pat pepper
story-wise is out in the mansion keep an
eye on you yeah you know kind of driving
you a little bit as well
so we just want to make it just feel
like yeah you're you know you this is
your this is your sparring partner this
is also the the new CEO of Stark
Industries Pepper Potts hi and we want
to make sure that she was really
integral into this story that's so cool
insane I can just fly around this for
hours and why are you playing the game
that no we are there like other things
that upgrade yeah so we have a whole
upgrade mechanics that
you doing Tony's garage and so yeah with
your impulse armor adding different
augments and other things that we're
gonna be talking about in the coming
months yeah but you have customizing
your suit is a big part of the game as
well that's great make sure there's a
big part of that progression element of
the game as well Josh I think you got
one more flight orbital to fly through
and then we're going to yeah that's how
you feeling over there oh man are you
kidding me I don't know if I'm kidding
you I'm just asking you one of things I
love how the game did is like that
really nice sunset or yeah that's coming
off the water
I mean look at the background and then
the canyon and the sky I mean you want
to kind of paint in some jet I feel like
Jeff rose oh I can do better than that
I'll go to the booth and get pulled you
been at the booth all right all the
pressure everybody watching me you know
yeah first time suiting up stuff this is
great tennis courts chicken tennis
courts yeah so so you just complete the
test flight you know how to do all the
mechanics now Josh and we have a before
but before we go into we're gonna kind
of explore the environment a little bit
more before we go into like this Combat
Challenge exactly right here Josh can
you like fly straight up over here right
from where you're at you can fly
straight up let's play a little tennis
are you playing a little tennis yeah
Josh doesn't like to listen to me that's
fine you look straight up and nice yeah
like just see then Wow good and then you
can put your hands above your head and
like fly straight down correct there it
is
and one of things we don't have this
demo is that we also have an ability
called ground pound which is just like
the rocket punch yeah you go vertically
and it's just like when Iron Man like is
I go yeah exactly just like the three
other three-point landing so that would
be in a subsequent you know what an
interesting challenge is about it's
great back right like how that all come
about the design we have an amazing
artist in the game who worked on it
really incredible skyboxes because it is
more developer focused I'll tell you
like a lot of that is actually 2d
because
we're not gonna render like that full 3d
environment so we it's all just like a
trick of the mind yeah so it feels like
it's a totally expansive world but most
of the detail is actually here yet like
you see and like please who do
environments
and in the water and all the texturing
and all that good stuff so as good Josh
just a look out look out to the Sun man
and make a wish that's how beautiful the
background looks you can just look out
there like you know what life is all
right I'm in the suit look at that I'm
not even in the suit I'm like it's gonna
be okay
so you don't wonder why nobody all here
standing on lines and and people smell
but you know what look at that Sun I
wish that Rhino Mike Rogers got toes but
it's gonna be okay I didn't get that toy
I wanna but look at that yeah when I'm
having my bad days I just have to fly
out here and that's how you game just
like being so real right all right man
so all right so Josh this all right so
let's get those weapons activated Josh
we're in this year drunk I'm ready to do
the combat yeah well they're ready to
the combat let's do that let's get it
poppin combat here we go and I love the
meters man it's like all these different
calculations talk to you there you go
you know one of the things we talk about
in the playstation blog post from
yesterday was that is all the elements
that go in here to make sure it feels
like a smooth experience as well right
like you notice like he hit a rock but
he didn't like hit it really hard
it bounces right along so here we go
here so let's check out some combat so
keep your head nice and steady Josh and
knock them out bong keep your head nice
and steady with all these drugs yeah
this is good man
I got a jaw around your left is talking
to you there we go nice so so uh check
it out Josh did it
yeah you going you can rock a place to
drink a rocket punch you can repulse
them oh do you need to be very close so
no more like no you really don't
Tony start just like he Jets right tour
if he if you keep it if you give you pay
close attention when when Josh hits the
melee button it'll tell him whether or
not he can make the punch nice
and so when he does it Rockets you
forward and you make the you execute the
melee attack you know the game will be
default normal
it'll be somewhat of a challenge but
we'll Ratchet it up - if you really want
the HUD changes different colors when
you're in combat versus just flying on
I'm impressed you noticed that Josh oh
yeah yeah and the when the HUDs blue
you're not in combat when when the when
the HUD detects that you're in danger it
goes to a kind of an orange yellow state
yeah yeah there you can see yeah nothing
drone what you got all right so we're
gonna introduce one of our harder drones
here you see three of three so here we
go
he's just gonna wreck it to charge out
it's like does serious damage feet let's
see if you take some damage blocking his
blockers buggin whoo yeah you can see
they notice the shield on them see how
the suit status light goes down just
watching me Josh take a little bit
damage so we can see like how that how
that play don't worry ever not judging
you not judging they are so this is one
you know the cool mechanics of the guys
came up well yeah he's back baby is that
players supposed to avoid him as he's
coming by and then just take him out
while while he's passing by but yeah
Josh an awesome job good job man laws
for Josh just joking that is so cool man
alright so the last objective is to is
to park his suit over at is a Malibu
mansion and I think that's the end of
this this this demo we brought to
comic-con which you can play over here
around the corner which we love
everybody to be able to check out do we
want to do like a little bit of quicker
run-through yeah let's do uh Josh is
there one you could do a little quicker
one you already a quicker well yeah yeah
it's just yeah get you to it get your
time going I don't know I mean alright
so yeah just land
there you go all right guys come on take
it off man so you come over top I know
I'm sorry baby I'm sorry it's over no
baby I'm sorry you got to take it off
will you all take care you guys think
right insane oh my god that is insane
good job Josh
good job man if you haven't played this
game yet it's literally right there yeah
not even ten feet away right everybody
go to the demo definitely demonstrate go
with it please if you've ever had a
desire and if you're a Marvel fan I'm
sure you have to know or feel what it's
like to fly around as Iron Man this
right here yeah it's literally oh do
they ask you how you feel back but
there's a controllers vibrate with every
repulsor you Jam with every boost you do
let me go up or down yeah all right it
felt smooth real smooth okay like this
screen is here yeah yeah yeah well one
of the interesting challenges about you
know showing off a VR game is that we're
showing off in this amazing screen but
it's only still a 2d experience for
everybody but Josh yeah that's why it is
so important that we want players to
come and play at the booth because it's
a totally different experience when
you're just wrapped in 360 they sign up
so you just can't rush over there so
good get onto the app and inside the
PlayStation app the PlayStation app then
you will definitely get your experience
the things possible the craziest thing
for me was seeing the breathing like we
need to have the breathing like you know
it's one of the things about the the
team it's so great it's not all top-down
for me or even from Marvel right we like
Marvel team wants our team to get
inspired and go like what if we did this
what if we did that and one of the
things I did was that they thought
wouldn't it be it realistic if I'm in
this HUD and I'm in this helmet you
might see some of your breath coming up
on the hood so that was a really really
cool idea that's all the team just put
in air conditioned in the suit will stop
you in there just like it does in VR but
you know what it doesn't matter once you
get in there for a couple minutes you
kind of lose the you kind of lose your
perspective on what's going on the real
and you're in it you're right but that's
like you're interested interjecting your
minds into Tony Stark because he
wouldn't make that that's how innovative
he is in you guys just captured that
that way yeah he's in a lot of it's like
the interesting things about Tony's
design is it's very simple it's very
elegant right he doesn't have a lot of
extraneous detail yeah and that's one of
the fun things about making the game is
that we have to we can't over engineer
it
we shouldn't add too many things yeah
that's not what Tony would do right he's
very sleek he's like he's a great
designer right man
Ironman has tons of upgrades to a suit
yes sir can we look forward to upgrades
you can look forward to you could
efficient you can officially look
forward to upgrades Josh again it
wouldn't be an Ironman experience if you
weren't a Tony Stark in the garage
listen to some music
you know tinkering away in your suit I
want to give players that ability to you
know again to not only be tone not only
be Iron Man but to be Tony Stark that's
so good
I don't know if this is a spoiler or not
I mean we did see a demo exhibit H but
here's where there was a video of our
Tony chasing a plane all right now now
is that like very interactive right so
you're starting to train a little bit
too as well is that what one of the big
epic moments so we want to think about
was what's what's more epic than you
know flying behind a jet that's about to
kind of crash into the ocean right
sometimes it comes across a little bit
on Rails it's totally not you fly
wherever you want to fly and you're not
only flying and shooting but we have
these things we called superhero
interactions super your interactions are
really leveraging the strengths of VR
the PlayStation VR motion controls and
so players are not just flying they're
not just shooting yeah but they're
they're fixing the wing pulling down the
landing gear you know they're putting
out fires because we really want to make
sure the players are not just flying and
shooting so so so when uh so like when
something is damaged like if the wings
on fire so you have to like in the
controller you switch to like it
automatically does fur it tells you like
switching to fire suppressant and then
players put out the fire on the engine
and then you fly over to like the
damaged wing and it shows you you got to
like physically move this this wing part
over I'm sure everybody's gonna see that
sooner than later I'm really excited to
show that office fire pun intended
[Laughter]
Payne the creative
amazing amazing work guys
guys this is Marvel's Ironman VR yeah
more news will be on Marvel comic out
the game it's going to be awesome
yes justly thank you joy I'm nori Davis
please big ol PlayStation app and sign
up on the app so you could do the demo
yourself you got experience this
yourself and this is Marvel your
universe